We live on a planet of insects.
They make up around 70%
of all known species on the Earth,
and their combined biomass
is 16 times that of humans.
300 million years ago,
giant dragonflies
with wingspans of 75 centimetres
soared amongst the tree ferns.
Nowadays, insects
are extraordinarily diverse,
existing in a bewildering array
of colours, shapes and sizes,
and they play a crucial role
in life on Earth.
They're food
for a great many animals,
including most birds, bats, lizards,
amphibians and freshwater fish.
80% of the world's wild
plant species depend on insects
to pollinate them,
as do three quarters of the plants
we grow for food.
It's no exaggeration to say
that without insects
many of us would starve.
But many types of insects
around the world are in big trouble.
Although measuring
insect populations is complex,
there are worrying signs.
A major 2020 study estimated
that globally land-dwelling insects
are declining by about 9%
per decade.
A German study found
that the biomass of flying insects
on nature reserves fell
by an alarming 76%
between 1989 and 2016.
In the United States,
populations of the monarch butterfly
are down 80% this century.
Some species, such as the comma and
speckled wood butterflies in the UK
are bucking the trend,
but the overall geographic range
of butterflies in the UK
has contracted on average
by 42% since 1976.
Invasive species
also take their toll.
Rats ate the St Helena giant earwig
to extinction
and have nearly exterminated
the giant weta of New Zealand.
Light pollution also lures moths
to bash themselves to death
and disrupts the timing
of insect life cycles.
It also disorients some dung beetles
who navigate
using the light of the Milky Way.
On top of all this, insects now
have to cope with climate change.
Some adaptable insects,
such as mosquitoes, cockroaches
and house flies, will benefit from
warmer temperatures and more rain.
Most insects will suffer.
Bumblebees are disappearing
from the southern edges
of their range,
overheating in their furry coats
as the climate warms.
Droughts, floods and forest fires
will ravage already depleted
insect populations.
In 1962, American biologist
Rachel Carson wrote Silent Spring,
warning that we were doing
terrible damage to our planet.
She wrote: "Man is a part of nature,
"and his war against nature
"is inevitably
a war against himself."
But what she witnessed
was just the beginning.
Since then,
insect-rich wildlife habitats
have been destroyed on a vast scale.
Soils have been degraded
and rivers choked with silt,
polluted or drained dry.
Farming, so reliant on insects
for pollination, is responsible
for a large part of their decline.
An estimated four million tonnes
of pesticides are released
into the global environment
every year.
So what can we do if we want
to protect our insects?
The obvious place to start
is by rewilding our gardens
and balconies,
inviting insects in
by planting wild flowers
and native shrubs,
reducing lawn-mowing and finding
alternatives to pesticides.
But individual actions
won't be enough.
Imagine green cities filled
with trees, vegetable gardens,
ponds and unmowed verges,
all free from pesticides
and buzzing with life.
A movement towards
insect and nature-friendly
sustainable farming is growing,
but it needs much more support,
both from governments and consumers.
It's not quite too late.
Most threatened insect species
have not yet gone extinct
and could quickly recover
if protected.
American biologist Paul Ehrlich
likened the loss of species
to randomly popping out rivets
from the wing of an aeroplane.
Remove one or two,
and the plane will probably be fine.
Remove ten or 20 or 50,
and at some point, there will be
a catastrophic failure
and the plane will fall
from the sky.
Insects are the rivets
that keep the planet running.
How many can be safely removed
from the plane before it crashes?